welcome to one of the final World
Championship match lectures there I've
been me maybe yeah I think we've done
every match so we're going to do other
stuff at some point and also since this
will never be shown it doesn't matter so
I decided to do the match between Laster
and Marshall Marshall was a good
American player but normally when he
played in events with Capablanca and
Laster and a lack in he wasn't winning
them not normally also Marshall like to
play wild and crazy so the games were
pretty interesting so I have a couple of
games in a position from the match which
I found good fact it describes here
Kasparov description in Cambridge
Springs 1904 Marshall had 11 wins 4
draws and no losses and they said hey he
should play Laster and then after he
played Lasker they wanted their money
back
so yeah Lasker eight wins seven draws no
losses and that was actually quite
common 150 years ago the world champion
in playing a world championship match
preferred to play somebody they would be
it because then you'd be the world
champion Stowe and you don't get to do
that nowadays you got to play they tell
you to play and that person might beat
you I mean not recently but so Lasker
Marshall was Marshall the second best
player in the world probably not even
top five maybe top ten maybe okay so the
first game was this is the first game of
the match and they played a real Lopez
he played d4 otherwise we could have
seen the Berlin in over 100 years ago
but okay the opening theory in 1907 was
slightly different than now now
everybody would either Castle or play d3
here I've been advocating for d3 for
years and finally some of the super GM's
are listening but castles is still more
common d4 is it interesting move
Marshall likes to play the interesting
move although an Alaskan I'm going to
show you it looks like Marshalls a
beginner but ok the first two
okay this should be 7e five then
probably this was theory in 1907 castles
D five attacks the night via Discovery
so Bishop takes c6 Knight takes and well
I have to tell a funny story because I
get paid by the hour there's two players
in Michigan
rated between twenty one hundred and
twenty to fifty named John Brooks and
Bob chiffonier they're about as opposite
as you can get Bob Schiavoni plays very
careful knows 100 moves of theory and
all his games her ten hours and they're
all draws and John Brooks is the
opposite he doesn't know any theory he
was instantly every move and he plays
wild and crazy and he likes to attack
and I would expect when they play that
the wild and crazy guy would win because
he would confuse the other guy but no
the boring slow always drawing never
moving player actually has a good
strategy which he employs against the
aforementioned player he plays wild and
crazy and sacrifices and attacks and his
opponent doesn't like that and then he's
defending all the time with probably
good positions we can't figure how to
defend and the the boring player
actually wins all the time because the
wild and crazy player doesn't get to
play his kind of game and that's what
Lasker did in Game one of this match he
played a sacrifice that's okay but it
was more than okay gets Marshall because
Marshall wants to sacrifice for a guy
known as a wild and crazy player white
doesn't have a lot of pieces developed
okay so he played rook e1 Queen h4
threatening the F pawn f6 opening up the
F file for the rook f3 and he sacrifices
a piece with F takes e5 it's not a bad
sacrifice it's not winning but it's very
hard for Marshall to defend a piece up
when they the annotator Kasparov said
Marshall wants to have black here he
wants to attack down a piece and the
idea is after you take the piece I play
d4 and now White has a decision
to make does he give the piece back or
does he let black attack and well this
position is okay for black black has a
lot of compensation for a piece and
whites Queen side looks like he's one of
Murphy's opponents so okay so he played
g3 and Kasparov gives a funny variation
here Bishop d2 bad move Bishop g4 check
in the Queen Queen obviously moves away
and now rook F - and you can see Black
has a lot of compensation for a piece
probably too much and I this the Bishop
g5 rook g2 check and we're going to
apply Bishop g2 mate or Queens you to
mate or Queen f3 and there's no defense
okay well Bishop d2 is sort of a silly
move but it saves the piece okay instead
Marshall played g3 the Queen move to f6
again if the bishop moves we got Queen
f2 and Bishop h3 and we're attacking so
Marshall gave back to piece with Bishop
takes d4 the line because far off gives
is Bishop to d2 Bishop to h3 threatening
mate mate mate mate ripped g1 forced and
Bishop f1 always play bishop f1 and I
assume the idea is to play Bishop e2 and
Bishop f3 that seems reasonable
yeah and well actually says that so
could you guys see that oh you guys
could see it too yeah I wasn't looking
over there it's too far away it was like
an inch away yeah you could just take it
the fact that's probably the best move
unfortunately I don't I don't like this
position whoops I like this position
okay when all 100 does that it's funny
when I do it is that it's funny and then
I assume Rick do you actually I assume
this I changed my assumption now and as
they say on Sopranos there's good
there's that good that's not good yeah
so well again looks like more fees
opponent is white all right so instead
of the correct way of playing which was
that and black has great compensation
Marshall gave back to piece tried to
Marshall
his defense no hold on what's way for
them to get it at home okay they just
got it at home all right and now
material is equal but again all of wise
pieces are on the first rank and as I
tell all of my students when you have
pawns on the dark squares we need a
bishop on g2 not a black bishop on g2 a
white bishop so in the long run white
said a lot of trouble now white doesn't
want to get checkmated because even in
1907 if you got checkmated you lost so
he played rook f1 and traded everything
off to a draw an endgame that wasn't
very drawn okay and now every move last
cravate a thread that's tough
played rook b8 threatening to be to pawn
b3 rip b5 he's going to swing his rook
over to h5 and a5 and e5 and attack all
of those pawns and a c5 and in fact
Marshall didn't want to lose a see to
pawn so he very drastically played c4
okay he didn't know at the time that c4
was explosive which we know now no
nothing no somebody get these people
encyclopedia
okay so c4 and then I like Chris burrows
crazy annotations is a fantasy was lost
to the endgame desert Wow
okay so yeah he gives lots of other
moves
he claims Knight d2 is the best move
then rook c5 which looks pretty annoying
rook see one Bishop a6 check and Bishop
d3 is pretty interesting move taking
advantage of the pin Knight f3 takes
take stay everybody takes everything and
well I would expect this would be a draw
that would be my expectation ever stops
analyzing so and then it rewrites etc so
there you go yeah okay but this has to
be a draw so Marshall has good drawing
chances if he plays correctly but
endgame was in his forte c4 rook h5
attacking the h2 pawn the King defends
it and now c5 and black has a passed
pawn
White has a we keep on blacks King can
move up the board and whites sort of
tied down here and hasn't developed yet
so black has a big advantage and black
didn't move his King up and his rook
swung over the other side of the board
very annoying and basically white is
just too passive black has a better rook
black has a better minor piece black has
a better King and black has a passed
pawn on d4 and the game well this
reminds you of some of the games in this
tournament
people aren't resigning when they should
in a lot of games the women's and the
championship and if you want a lesson in
not resigning you should look at the
games from the early 1900's they didn't
resign until the computer found 10 ways
to give checkmate ok so this game has
been over for a while because basically
black is a king ahead blacks King is all
over the place and white just can't move
but there's no reasoning until you lose
all of your pawns so that's what
happened yeah super grandmasters today
don't like play 90 to 91 I'll do that
but the truth hurts and yeah now there's
a lot of pawns going to Queen okay and
now since we really can't stop f2 check
even Marshall resigned yeah yeah a very
good game from Lasker and that was the
first game with a match and usually when
you're white you know even then you were
trying to press for a win but he was
sort of on the defense of the whole game
because Lasker sacrificed a piece and
made Marshall defend MP sacrifice was
probably sound and that might have been
one of the best games of the match well
I don't the worst game of the match was
because I have it I have it here okay
this was a very interesting game black
was slightly better because white has a
weak C pawn this was game 3 this was the
next game that Marshall had white
obviously he's doing a lot better here
than he was in the first game
and Lasker played 94 attacking the
c-pawn as many times as humanly possible
and Marshall played Knight takes f7
because that's how Marshall rolls and
when I looked at this game I was like
did Laster miss Knight takes f7 and I
was like yeah I think he missed like
takes f7 okay and the purpose of 96 f7
is if you take with a rook you lose your
rook on c8 and I would think if Laster
had seen Knight takes f7 he probably
wouldn't have done this on the other
hand he does sacrifice the exchange
again an attack it's not winning butts
the kind of position again Marshall
wants to have black he wants to
sacrifice an attack and he doesn't like
this defensive kind of stuff so maybe
Laster did do it for psychological
reasons he took sacrificing the exchange
and now he has to save his queen
but f4 is also hanging and the problem
with queen g4 is rook takes f4 seems
quite annoying so he played Queen b7 and
black isn't winning here by any means
it's just more pleasant to have black
because black has a big attack and if
two supercomputers are playing probably
the game would end in a draw but okay
1907 defense wasn't the highest level
and it wasn't Marshalls forte now
Marshall played pretty well considering
Queen g5 was played black wants to play
rook f2 and then probably hard to defend
after that so king h2 was played now he
can play Queen ch-check in Queen g4 if
you play rook f2 and my rook can slide
over and defend Queen g3 check Knight d2
threatening the rook on b1 and Knight f3
check leading to me Queen takes d5 check
and king h1 the best move
so actually Marshalls defending
excellently so far so far in last
replayed Knight f3
so it's pretty funny lasker was known as
this sort of a counter-puncher and
Marshall was known as sac all his pieces
at play for me and in both games of the
match where Marshall was white the
opposite happened
Lasker was sacrificing playing for
attack not necessarily winning but
putting Marshall on his heels you have
to take the knight because queen h2 was
made Chuck and black plays for the win
by playing the move rook f4 and black
wants to play rook age four with
advantage yeah
and unfortunately for Lasker he didn't
find the best defense I mean I don't
blame him I know the best defense and I
forgot it so I resigned yeah I think the
only move is Queen h5 yeah and I think
computer says it shouldn't end in the
draw because if we if we trade the Queen
for the rook and white has to works for
a queen why does it pass deep on his
Kings pretty open so that should be
equal but it's also possible Marshalls
saw Queen h5 but played for the win or
as I like to say played for the loss
okay that's a knock on where I would
agree with me not good work he was
talking about I shouldn't have played so
aggressively against Cara Juana
okay that's what he does so he didn't
play Queen h5 e played Queen d8 check
and now if black plays Rick h4 that
would be just like white playing Queen
h5 but now it's White's turn to move so
Marshalls like oh boy have a free move
unfortunately he didn't see blacks
threat yeah you should see your
opponent's threat when they're meeting
you Rick h4 is not the threat can
somebody tell me what black does if it's
blacks turn to move you at home Queen
takes pawn
that's good move I know if it's the best
move it's a good move I think he stopped
that you play Rick f1 yeah yeah he
stopped that he didn't see the other
threat which is even better
and actually in my game with Fidel
Corrales MNS which I've mentioned on
every lecture I've ever given and when
I'm walking down the street talking to
myself I was threatening rook on the H
file mate and he stopped it because he's
a grandmaster and then I moved my rook
somewhere else throw any Brook somewhere
else on the edge from a that he was like
oh and that's what lected yeah rook age
four was mate now it's not not rook age
five is made man the truth hurts
well the only move I see that stops
Queen a trick h5 is Queen e8 yeah I
don't see another move right I don't see
another one and then if I'm correct and
I'm not using my computer so I'm a
little afraid I think this is checkmate
yeah so yeah fact rook F one made rook
f5 even stronger because a go F one for
the King so he didn't see rook f5
because if he saw it he wouldn't play
trick F one so yeah blaster was right
marshal good attacker defender yeah not
a good defender now the last game was
very strange in fact one of the reasons
I have a lower opinion of Steinitz than
maybe you do is I've seen some of the
Steines Trigorin games and I have to
unsee those games because those those
games weren't good now for some reason
which I can't quite grasp yet although I
see it a lot at the lower level Steinitz
and other players of that era
they played fantastic games steinem
spawned Varda Laban is one of the
greatest games ever however they also
played the worst and you can see some of
that here at the championship
some of our favorite players from the
past and present like gotta calm ski
just making blunders he's never made
before against Jeffries Young and Wesley
so like just losing in one move not
seeing things and a lot of the top
players from the late 18-hundreds early
1900s I'm like wow that's the greatest
game ever but if I look at all of their
games that I'm only wait a minute what
happened and the name
see I'm going to show you is not good
and I think when players are behind it a
match they tend to go crazy and they
they know that if they keep drawing
they're going to lose the match so they
play a little too aggressively and
although Nakamura played too
aggressively against Cara Juana it was
sort of you know it was sort of a calm -
aggressively here Marshall went went too
far okay and I'll show you the whole
game so yeah back in the day people
played everything Alaska would play E 4
d 4 C 4 he didn't care and then in the
60s and 70s most of the players just
played one move and now they play
everything if any of the top-10 players
the world have white or black you don't
know what they're going to do they could
play any opening because they they have
to learn everything that way it's not
that easy to prepare for them ok so this
was a Marshall Marshall it was a French
and Marshall tried to play the Marshall
gambit and there's two Marshall game
it's that I know there might be more
there's the more famous one and the semi
Slav where white plays efore and
sacrifices upon but also in this
position
Marshall like to play that move c5 which
nobody plays now it's the Marshall
gambit and then I guess after a while he
said that's not good
but but it's named after him and
nobody's played it I don't know the last
time anybody played it but it's called
the Marshall game and he played it now
he played Knight f6 which is the normal
move and in fact this is from
yesterday's game this is so Nakamura so
there you go
and Lasker played a very unusual move
last year was a great psychologist he
tried to throw his opponent off make
moves he wasn't expecting and he played
Bishop d3 it's a very strange move it's
played occasionally but usually they're
kidding ok Bishop d3 is not ok the main
moves if you look at any database
there'll be 10,000 games with e5 and
10,000 years of Bishop g5 and when
people are kidding they take which I've
done what I'm usually kidding ok an
actor Bishop d3 marshal couldn't help
self marshals like wait a minute I can
play an improved version of my gambit
it's not a give anymore
c5 so well this is much better than
usual because the white queen isn't
doing anything on the D file the deep
ones are all safe for black well no if I
play C 5 but ok C 5 is probably not that
bad
and then after Knight f3 yeah okay
Marshall played very anti positional
trying to win upon and ital my students
don't ever make this move so maybe I
should tell him to make it and they
won't
interesting reverse psychology and he
played c4 and black has pressure on the
center and so in the French defense well
you play c4 it's for the very specific
reason you want to close the Queen side
and often black puts his king on the
Queen side or starts advancing all of
his pawns here he did it to win upon
again last row the brilliant
psychologist sacrificing material every
game putting Marshall on the defensive
okay he took 95 are we going to be able
to save this pawn I don't think so so
black has played a lot of moves but it
only has one piece out Lasker has three
pieces out and is ready to castle
ready to play Bishop g5 if necessary
ready to win his pawn back c4 is not a
good move Bishop to d6 castles a6 okay
when you're behind in development you
don't keep making pawn moves I actually
have no idea why he played a six because
if his idea to play b5 and defend his
pawn y could take the pawn two different
ways now in fact a6 just looks like a
terrible move Knight takes e4 h 6 yeah
okay and then f3 just like in Game one
when Lasker played f6 to open up the
file for his rook same thing okay now is
this the position where you went totally
crazy or was it one more move let's say
okay was it wasn't this move EF Bishop
f3 great position for white it looks
like a black Mar Deemer except White's
not
upon so white has open f file for his
rook White's night on C fours beautiful
White's Bishop on F he's beautiful these
pieces all terrible hard to get them
developed very nice position for Wyatt
and Marshall went totally crazy here I
mean unbelievable okay he played Bishop
takes H to check now again I said
earlier in the lecture I look at some of
the games of the older players and just
brilliant and then I look at this game
and I'm like what what's going on this
is a real Cheney to match
okay now it's possible I'm not saying
it's true
it's possible he thought Queen c7 check
one is piece back if that's the case if
that's the case then it's just a
horrible blunder if he did it on purpose
sacking a piece I can't even I can't
explain how silly that is unfortunately
Queen c7 track does not win the piece
back because I play 95 so maybe he
missed that I don't know maybe maybe if
he didn't miss that and he intentionally
sacrificed a piece I don't even know
what to say okay I don't even know which
is worse and now h5 with a winning
attack yeah so this is a world
championship match this isn't a joke so
when you see games like this liberal
championship man sir you're like wait a
minute the guys today are better than
the guys a long time ago
now of course Marshall and Landon always
play this badly he has a lot of
brilliant wins he has the famous move of
Levitsky which move was that Queen g3
very good okay fact in a similar game I
lost to belly offski he played Knight g3
is very similar and man I didn't see 9
g3 why was that a good move anyway h5
what so I'm just hoping he thought Queen
c7 check one the piece and he missed 95
otherwise his judgments not the best
look if I was one of his sponsors I'd be
like this ship and h5 mmm get my money
back somehow so you can't checkmate your
opponent when you have an Opie
your poet has all our pieces out okay so
this ship f4 not white has the
initiative black I mean this is just
like two little kids playing that's a
real championship match like if my
student was black and they were rated
like 400 I'd be like yeah I told you not
to Sag appease g8 it's hard to believe
this is a World Championship match takes
94 and again not resigning is weird now
if you want to see something weird do
you
Marshall played 97
what would the brilliant chess players
in the audience play now followed by
mate yeah it surprised the audience you
surprised you at home
96 check either one rook f7 me you did
Lasker play that no yeah I don't know
that's that's why you know we talk about
the greatest players of all time we have
like as far off and Fisher and Carlson
and Karpov and then these guys a long
time ago a little suspicious now thing
is when you're so winning you don't use
don't care so last year I've been like
well this the light you might have lost
interest a long time ago that's a good
excuse actually like if Lasker is like
every legal move wins then it doesn't
really matter that he missed me
just strange me to miss Knight d6 rook
f7 yeah look at these is he getting man
over here yeah
okay so queen g4 also good and there's a
very slight possibility very slight he
saw the mate but you know let him suffer
a little yeah make make him suffer okay
95 takes King f8 and the truth hurts
yeah yeah but not resigning is also very
strange that's also weird okay and here
he resigned but why resign now how's
this different than every other position
sometimes I'm playing somebody lower
rated like much lower rated and I'm
really winning I'm
a lot and then they're like hang upon
they're like ah then they resigned then
like what you were down at work in a
bishop what the planets do they think so
yeah I don't blame Lasker for missive
the me because he I think he lost
interest in the game completely anyway
you can see that whoever backed Marshall
probably wasn't too happy after that
game like wait a minute I put money on
you yeah so some of the games were
one-sided and especially the World
Championships a long time ago because
often the world champion picked their
opponent always a good idea and also the
opponent had to get backers and pay the
prize fund right it was up to the
opponent to secure financial backing so
the match would take place but that
meant you had a chance to be world
champion if you had enough backers and
money it's like I would play you for
more championship and some of Alekhine's
opponents were bit iffy but okay
nowadays they're not kidding around when
you see world championship match it
could go either way you could I mean
ananka non could be Carlsen because he
could get him in a couple opening traps
because he prepared to move 30 and then
draws the rest the games so you anybody
can win now can karaoke be Carlsen no
absolutely not no terrible no he's
probably not gonna win a game either
Carlson is good but okay it's not an
andhe gun
that's something but it would have been
much nicer for everybody if it was Cara
Wan especially since in theory the
matches in New York and practice I don't
know but in theory when the mayor of New
York said this match will be great so
beware do not have it in New York after
the mayor says it's going to be great so
I guess it'll be in New York there's
probably a few people in New York who
can afford it when I say a few I mean
hundreds yeah when I say hundreds I mean
thousands yeah Sikhs I go to millions
now just thousands yeah so the match is
supposed to take place in November in
New York and that World Championship
match will be higher quality than this
one now since we've covered almost every
world championship match and I did sort
of a fake one last week I did the
semi-finals since that Fisher was very
unlikely to play so
the de facto World Championship we're
going to probably start a new lecture
series in May with other kinds of old
players from the early 1900s 1802 talk
about those guys but World Championship
matches were tough back then because you
know in the 1800s Early 1900s they
weren't really flying to the destination
and the conditions weren't the best the
prize money wasn't the best and as you
can see the games weren't the best but
as you can also see Lasker played pretty
well at Marshall yeah not not as good
they did a computer study of all the
world champions and of the players
before 1960 Lasker made very few ears
ten times fewer errors and sinus that's
ten times better is good kappa blanka me
didn't make a lot of errors but you know
a lot of drawings - Wow well Paul Morphy
is my favorite so yeah Paul Morphy is
the best right if you played frank
marshall now let's see i can't make a
prince joke because for you he just died
today for you guys I can make a prince
joke for you guys but not for them
they're still trying to handle it for
those of you who don't know which is
very weird if you don't Prince died
today but okay but for you but for you
guys he died like three weeks ago so
yeah well don't know when this video
comes out the people at home but you
won't know now yeah now it's just salt
lies but in three weeks we'll know right
yeah he'd actually been sick for a while
and he actually cancelled some of his
concerts so my guess was he was at home
instead of in the hospital probably the
hospital would have been safer because
he'd been sick for a while but yeah okay
that's my last remark show lecture and
next week my deaf adult championship
match lecture we'll find out in that
game right there martial god I'm so
badly
I might as well just start a pawn store
well if you thought that I give him less
credit than her to give him I the only
thing that makes any sense is he thought
Queen c7 Trek won the piece back and
then he didn't see 95 and that's also
strange if he's like h5g forever ga then
he's yeah he's then all then I'll play
my match because he can't that's such a
silly yeah yeah because it's just silly
well thanks for coming to lecture and
I'll see you guys next week